good morning everybody welcome to day
two of the Microsoft Research Latin
America faculty summit very excited to
welcome you to this day it's sort of the
crescendo of our event jam-packed I know
it's early but if we don't get started
now we're going to be later later later
all day and then we'll miss the party
tonight which is the most important part
of the entire event so no way are we
missing that one I'm really excited to
be here and to introduce our next
speaker Judith Bishop I've known for a
long time and is an amazing colleague so
let me get my notes so I can make sure
and read her awesome bio she is the
director of computer science in
microsoft research in the united states
in redmond her role is to create strong
links between Microsoft's research
groups and universities on a global
scale she encourages projects
conferences and engages directly in
research programs as well I've worked
with her on a project called try F sharp
we're doing some exciting things they're
actually touch develop code hunt the BBC
micro bit which I believe is also being
discussed at this event and latest is
the quantum simulator called liquid she
now drives the Open Source Initiative
and her expertise is primarily in
programming languages and distributed
systems with a very actually a very
strong practical bias which is pretty
neat after her degrees her undergraduate
degrees in South Africa she received her
PhD from Southampton in the UK and then
was a professor at University of
Pretoria in South Africa she's an ACM
distinguished educator has received the
ifip silvercorp award among others and
she is also a fellow of the british
computer society and the Royal Society
of South Africa please give a
warm welcome to Judith Bishop
you
good morning everyone I'm delighted to
be here this latum summits and I want to
thank very much evil in Vieques Jaime
Puente and of course Roy Zimmerman for
inviting me and setting everything up so
well so when would you not want
something for free that's going to make
you friends and actually is going to
make what you do better that's actually
what people think open source is all
about I'm going to tell you much more
deeply what it is and how it affects us
in industry in particular actually in
Microsoft because that's what I know
best but I will bring in more general
terms from industry as I've seen it
operating among my colleagues in other
companies as well I'm going to spend
half the talk on that part and then most
of the talk the other half on Microsoft
researchers offerings in the open source
arena so let's get going open source
myths open source is often equated with
big software which is in the public
domain and so anyone can use it or just
freeware in other words it's stuff
that's free and therefore it's open
source or it's not enforced by anyone
and some of those words are good for
industry and some of them are not good
for industry same for academics of
course but generally speaking these are
nice things to have what is it from the
point of view of Microsoft or from
industry they jump straight into the
legal aspects and they say actually it's
also a licensing model and they're a lot
of aspects to the licensing
I have to admit straight off I don't
understand these completely first of all
I don't have to because when you are in
a great big company you have a large arm
of people who are responsible for
handling the licensing and the licensing
can get very complex the main word to
retail on the second line you get a
license that gives you the right to copy
modify and redistribute the code and
that is the most important thing all
right then can you make money out of it
and so on well depends on the license
and it depends on variations but the
point is that you could copy the code
you can modify it and you can
redistribute what you've done as a new
piece of code it also comes with no
representations or warranties and that's
interesting so unlike software which is
sold by a company like Microsoft or by
Apple for example Oracle actually sell
software when it's soft me like this you
can actually distribute it and say use
it I'm not going to support it and and
that is a little scary when you think
about it of course you can support it
and there are fantastic models of this
which are backed with open source
software as we know IBM have been very
successful at doing this with their red
hat and so on redistribution also
triggers certain other licensing
obligations and that's where it starts
going down a chain and the whole
licensing thing is a mixture I'll give
you one good example of that as we go on
what is much more interesting
from our point of view here is that open
source is also a development methodology
it changes completely the way that
software in a company is developed so
here are just six ways in which software
has to change if we are going to use
open source software inside a company
and send it out as well we need to
regard our users as developers or put it
the other way the people who are
contributing to the open-source software
are also our users we have to take into
account their desires and their wishes
very early on in the process and that
makes a big difference two features two
requirements specifications and so on
early release you you don't have
releases way out there three-quarters
away three quarters of a year away you
keep releasing frequent integration and
so on open source also enforces very
high modularity of code because you need
to put things into smaller groups which
can be open source separately or which
you replace with open source software
separately so that's actually a good
thing as you know in code design hi
modeler modularity is regarded as a good
thing and then dynamic decision making
that can be a bit tricky in a company
where you have large software groups
some software group seed companies are
hundreds of people and if you are taking
decisions based on what somebody out
there said or submitted to your software
it could be difficult it could disrupt
it could be disruptive so all of these
change the way you think and the way
that you develop your code so this is
what's been going on inside companies
for a while and certainly with inside
Microsoft you could regard it as having
three actors they're the creators of the
software where the users of the software
and then they're that contributors once
you've created and you've used it and
everything is in this great big open
source repository so that's the word
that people talk about a lot the
repository and at different times
industrial companies will engage in all
three of those so sometimes companies
will be using other people's software
they will find some neat little
algorithm or some neat little piece of
code and they will insert it into a new
piece of software and they will use the
open source and contribute to open
source all of those happen now you might
ask about that last one why would a
company encourage you allow even their
employees to contribute in company time
to open source what's in it for them
well it turns out that this is part of
the whole ecosystem of open-source
development that if you contribute you
become part of the community and then
eventually in time you get back from the
community what you put in moreover
developers are very keen to do this and
that probably that last one is one of
the hard
first ones to step over using yes we'll
use what you've got and we'll use it for
free but that's easy we'll create stuff
and you can have it if we don't feel
that it's worth too much in IP but the
third one is company time of employees
and that has to be done as well if you
want to be really part of the whole
open-source ecosystem so all of those
and we'll see how they are done so if
we're doing all of that what's in it for
the software industry and I'm going to
tell you straight away that I did not
write the slide this was written for me
by our people in the Microsoft
open-source a part of the company so we
have a special part of the company that
assists and promotes the open-source
aspect of what we do so you can
understand the words here are a little
bit promotional first of all it gives us
speed if we're using other people
software we can go faster to market by
getting comments earlier on the software
we can find out that our software is
more robust what that really means is
other people are getting the bugs out
for us and that's a good thing as you
know in open-source people submit bug
reports to the repos and that's a good
thing if you get a trusted community out
there who like your software who want to
submit bug reports that's great
interoperability interoperability is
something which a company like Microsoft
is very very keen on we want to make
sure that our software will run on all
platforms and then many ways of doing
this obviously open source is one of
them
and it certainly gives us business
growth because we are not just running
on the Windows platform we can then run
on other platforms as well give you some
examples of those in a moment but
through the open source community we can
get that expertise going and then the
thriving technology ecosystem out there
I have to say and you probably know this
already that young people in particular
are very attracted to open source
software they feel that it's a place
where even if they don't contribute they
are allowed to contribute so there's a
freedom there and it is a domain where
one wants to be and a forward-looking
company like Microsoft certainly wants
to play in this in this game and it just
gives you more choice more competition
and that's where we would like to be so
our leader and CEO satya nadella made a
statement last April so this was April
2015 that industry embraces open source
in fact he said Microsoft embraces open
source and I went to check on this and i
found that of course it is true every
company is doing open source and i
checked up on various reports by
independent observers of the yeah just
off the ecosystem out there rather than
looking on the websites of the companies
which do tend to show all their
different offerings as you can see here
you can see that we have the big
companies like Apple and IBM Facebook
and so on they all have their open
source software
but it's not just those it's the next
level down that are also using open
source to promote what they do and to
develop what they do and so that's
interesting and there's some very big
names they're like G EMC I think there's
a emc lab here and maybe they even some
MC people in the audience here VMware
verizon is a telephone company and
Internet company in the u.s. so it's
pervasive people are relying on it and
it's not going to go away right when
actually did open source start inside
Microsoft it's very interesting to find
out when now you won't be able to see
too much detail on this slide that
doesn't matter what's interesting is
that it's it happened more than 10 years
ago and we had this trajectory of
involvement in open source very slowly
parts of the company we're starting to
move into open source and you can see
the little linux penguin there in the
middle and at that stage we decided we
were going to have some kind of Linux
and they were other ones like nodejs
dotnet that's the purple one up on the
top there until larger and larger parts
of the software that was on offer or
that we wanted to incorporate or that we
bought were involved in open source and
these were made announced as they went
in bits and pieces bits and pieces until
eventually we came to that conclusion
which as I told you such a and came gave
last year how does the open-source
actually work inside
microsoft itself well they're different
ways one of the ones is that we can
incorporate open source inside existing
large tools now you might know about
visual studio visual studio is our
environmental software editor that is
used for the development of software and
inside of that is an open source section
which is called Python tools and Python
tools is for development of Python and
it was brought over from the Python
community as an open source piece of
software that Python tools are open
source when visual studio is shipped as
a actual piece of code it is shipped
with this open source and as a result if
you look inside and you can actually you
will find that there are about a hundred
and fifty different licenses which are
shipped with it so this is the licensing
aspect which I told you about because
different pieces of those Python tools
and other pieces which are inside Visual
Studio which are open source have to
have their attributive licenses shipped
with them most users never see that but
it's very very important that they're
there the other part of visual studio
which is interesting I think for all
academics in the audience that I think
most of you are is that there is a code
version it's called the code edition of
Visual Studio it's a bit tricky that
word code it doesn't mean code it means
the code edition is the academic edition
actually which is free
and that one is free to students and
that one is also available on Mac on
Linux and free to all students and in
that you will also find this open source
software so all in all you can have
hybrid systems another example of this
which I'll be telling you about later is
where the company can actually make a
lot of money out of a particular piece
of code and yet have open source in it
but not all of it and and that is what
makes you realize that open source is
not giving away all the IP it's just
giving away the software but using and
developing in the open source model now
openness is a word which Microsoft has
used a lot and openness is the making
axis of standard technology what they
say really happen so it's not always
possible to have different versions for
all the different platforms I've just
mentioned available but one way of doing
it is to take things to a meta level and
to leverage something like the azure a
cloud and then what you can do is you
can put the software like the Windows
software or a bunt 0 software or any of
that inside the cloud and then put it up
so this isn't really open source
development but it is making sure that
we have open software it's it's a
slightly different version it's made
much more
easy by the availability of open source
software on Reapers public Reapers which
are out there so one example i'd like to
mention is the windows sdk which for
facebook and we probably a lot of you
use facebook i know that i have to use
it to make sure that i can keep in touch
with my family and there's a windows sdk
for facebook and that is available open
source so Facebook itself is not a
product from Microsoft but this little
SDK is and you can incorporate that into
whatever it is that you want to do and
that was made available and you can see
that these you won't be able to read it
but it was developed by the windows
develop a platform team early in july
last year and the open-source team at
microsoft released it as an
implementation of the facebook sdk so
they made that so that things could be
easier and people could use on different
platforms what needed to be done right
now actually this week in Texas there's
the biggest open source conference
called Oskan and Microsoft had a
planeload of people going to that
conference it also had one of the
keynotes there by Joseph sirach who is
the corporate vice president of one of
our units and the whole idea was around
Microsoft using and developing in the
open source arena so these would be the
people who make these kind of things
happen and they certainly were there to
hire people and to expose what is being
done in the open source
so I'd like to switch now to what's
going on in Microsoft Research which of
course is where we come from those of us
who are here talking to you over these
couple of days often we have pictures of
buildings but i decided i'll have a
picture of the trees outside microsoft
which are very beautiful in all in all
seasons so Microsoft Research was
established in 1991 and those of you who
good at arithmetic will know that that
meets that with 25 years old this year
and we are happy to be having an
anniversary over a thousand scientists
we have nine different units of course
one of them is here in Brazil and and we
have 24 research areas they keep
changing but if you look on the website
today it says they're 24 now inside this
enormous organization there is a lot
going on in open source the problem was
as you can see that it was very
difficult for people to find out what
was going on you could go to any project
page of an area that you were interested
in and you could look up a project it
was not really evident whether it was
opens also not open source and so on so
that's why we started within Microsoft
this initiative to really expose and
make clear what is microsoft researchers
a contribution to the open source
environment since 2014 there's been a
huge trend towards researchers open
sourcing their software we now have over
50 projects now that sounds perhaps like
a small number but it's quite a large
number because one of the things about
an open source project
is that you can't just put it out there
and leave it it's got to be looked after
projects need to be curated projects
that are open source will start to get
contributions and you need to look at
those contributions you will eventually
if your project is popular start
building a community and their various
ways of controlling that community if
you're a single person you might have to
say whoa I can't take that many
contributions but on the other hand if
it is a very popular project maybe you
can get more people to help you with it
the projects are not just for academics
that definitely aimed at other
developers they're aimed at our internal
Microsoft products as well so there's a
huge variety and the way I want to go
through this is to show you the example
of some of our products that we've got
out there our projects and in the
research showcase you can come and look
at more of them so as I said the way we
dealt with us as we set up this portal
and the other thing and now you're going
to hear me mention this word for the
first time is we decided that it was
good to try to move to a single
repository which turns out to be github
many of you will equate open source with
github but github is not the only place
where open source can be they were and
are other places where you can put open
source it just turns out that github has
become probably at the moment the most
popular and Microsoft has a special
relationship with github now we have
people who work on both sides they come
and work at Microsoft and help us and we
help them github have an academic arm as
well
and we are very good friends with them
they helped us with promotion of of our
products so what exactly have we got
well we've got tools in specialized
domains so here are the 12 domains we've
got verification cryptography
visualization programming cloud
computing education of course artificial
intelligence hardware systems science
documents interesting one that but we'll
see why and society and then from those
we can pick out and classify all of the
open source software we have and then
you can go and look at it and this is
what it looks like so you get a list of
the projects and you can then from there
go and have a look at what a project is
and whether it would be of use to you so
instead of going to all 50 if you're in
artificial intelligence you can see
while at the moment they're ten but next
week there might be 12 and we also list
them not in alphabetical order which
might sound but strange but we list them
in a strange order so that your eyes are
encouraged to go and look at the ones
that are new and one of the ones that is
new it is CN TK our computational
network toolkit and there's a talk about
that at the summit so I'm going to spend
the next few slides just looking ATS and
highlighting the some of these projects
so the computational network toolkit is
for mission-critical AI research and the
idea here is that how do you measure how
well a project is doing in the open
source domain how do I measure it as a
project leader of my initiative well one
of the ways I can do it is to go and
look on github and github gives you a
lot of statistics sometimes it's a bit
irritating because those of you who are
great guitar people will know that the
statistics only go back two weeks and if
you forget to go and look at something
every two weeks you then miss out on
some statistics but anyway this one
you'll see is that it has had mergers
proposed and closed issues very very
recently and I only took this a pull
yesterday so we'll see that it had an
interesting merge which was called the
bug fix on grayscale images are now
assumed by default if the number of
channels blah blah blah so everybody can
see what's going on with a project
brilliant all right and in particular
the person who submitted that can see
that and that is now been fixed and
merged into the main stream there's a
proposed one here which says sublinear
memory of optimization on resnet
interesting proposal and maybe that will
be merged later on so all of this is
public and it's public for the team and
public for people code contracts is a
much older project code contracts is a
language agnostic way to express coding
assumptions in.net so this is a way of
making your programs more secure and
it's an active developer community for a
long time managed by mike barnett in
microsoft and it's been moved over to
the
mainstream of visual studio so code
contracts is now in visual studio if you
get visual shooter you get code
contracts so it's one of those pieces of
open source inside he has another piece
of way that you can find out how well is
the project doing an open source you can
look at the contributions now you can
see that it around about this time that
we're looking at it had closed on 40 I
have a manager and one of his little
sayings is is that a big number it's 40
a big number and initially I was thrown
by such a question so you have to go
back and think about it is is that a big
number well it is a big number because
if it was 4,000 you wouldn't be able to
deal with them 40 is a big number of
contributions at any one day and that's
fantastic to have that kind of people
contributing in fact there are studies
that have shown that if you have an
active a project like this you can
actually forgo having up to two
developers that you would otherwise have
to pay for in the company just by
leveraging and using the open source
community as and of course you're giving
back to the open source community in
other ways and down below you can see
that the source code has had 437 commits
and so many branches and so on and so on
Daphne some of you might have heard of
Daphne Daphne is a programming languages
programming language with a verifier
this is also a very mature project it
was open source right from the beginning
and it was on a different repo
github it was on codeplex run BAM wrist
and leno and he spent a lot of time
making sure that Daphne would run on
different platforms in fact five
platforms so if you go to Daphne com so
yes that'll work Daphne com you'll be
able to download it for whatever
computer you're running he's now since
moved it over to get up and you can once
again see that these are graphs from
codeplex and he's got about forty
contributors going at any one time he
has some main contributors there's a
post grad student at imperial college
but we all almost want to give a medal
to because the student has contributed
so much to the project another thing
that's interesting about open source
software or about any kind of software
is that you can make it run in a browser
and this was pioneered by projects like
Daphne and Microsoft is very proud that
we can do this so instead of having to
download software put it on your
computer ensure that it runs and so on
which can be daunting for people you
could try it out by just opening your
browser and then checking that it runs
and seeing whether you like the
experience so a lot of software which
comes out of this particular group in
Microsoft runs this way that's called
rods for fun and there it is r is e rise
for fun and that particular screenshot
comes from deftly in rise for fun touch
develop is another one and there's going
to be part of touch develop will also be
in the research showcase and the BBC
micro bit it was created for apps on
phones tablets laptops and so on as a
language
cific Lee designed for using your finger
on all of these devices many years ago
and that was led by tomball and it's now
moved over to these little chips but
you're going to be able to see and use
and the history of that run was
interesting it wasn't open source and
there was no intention to open source it
but we wanted to have it in a in a
system in the USA called hour of code
you might have heard it it was a
fantastically organized and publicized
event with the ACM even President Obama
was promoting it for children to learn
to code but they would only put projects
on the website if they were open source
so he said all right we'll open source
it however the project itself doesn't at
the moment actively accept contributions
you can look at the code and you can
branch from it but you it's it's not
accepting contributions perhaps you can
discuss that with Jonathan and I might
be wrong at the moment but that was hard
was a while back and it runs on any
device it also runs on your browser and
that's a great thing and one of the
other things here is it has its own open
repository so it runs of the cloud and
it has its own little cloud place where
all its own language scripts run and you
can see how many they are which is
enormous so it has at the moment 157
Forks when i took this probably more now
so people have forked it off now this is
a very big project it's called Project
aliens it's headed up by one of our
distinguished scientists called full
Bernstein
and it's a distributed interactive
application model for virtual actors now
that sounds very formal in fact this is
the brains behind the computer game
called halo and some of you or maybe
your children or someone have run halo
and it's automatically deployed in the
cloud and it Taylor of course is a major
revenue base for Microsoft but inside it
the streaming part is open source so you
can go and look at how it works and you
can use the same streaming base if you
want to for your things and you can see
that when i took this clip here they
were 11 authors and they were not all in
microsoft because i know that the team
is two people at the moment there were
three ones left there to left so there
we have 11 people from all over the
world contributing f-sharp was referred
to in the introduction the difference in
f-sharp is that it is a project that was
open sourced right from the beginning
done sign use in our cambridge lab said
i'm going to have this language it's
going to be open source and then it
became so well used and so mature that
they created what's called a foundation
and they moved it out of microsoft into
the foundation microsoft store supplies
f sharp as part of its languages but the
foundation looks after it and it has
community projects it runs workshops
does all of these things which
foundations do so there's such a huge
community around this that runs itself
mots allah is another one in another
part of the world that has its own
foundation as well eclipse as a
foundation so very mature open source
projects
move that way and finally Madoka I said
I was going to come to documents Madoka
is something I really think you should
take a look at it is a markdown
processor which runs in the cloud and it
enables you to duel a tech type document
processing but in the cloud and with
other people all working on the same
document it's beautifully tooled you can
use different repos you can use Dropbox
you can use github you can use a sure to
store your projects your documents and
it's multi-platform run on anything as
it's sorted it's written in a specific
type of computer language called coker
with Donlin as the leader there and it's
also open a source and it's nice thing
about it is it's open to extension hi
modularity so if you want to add
chemistry or physics modules to this
they are already quite a few modules but
if you wanted to add more to be really
easy to do it has over 2,000 new users
in a week and very high usage already
it's getting a big user base here so
with all of that we decided then one of
the things we were going to do is find
out whether students would like this
kind of project open source did students
like it and so we ran a challenge this
year to see if students up there would
be able to use these projects and just
to do a bit of advertising these were
some of the students who won the prod
won the challenge which was announced
two weeks ago so they had a lot of money
in prizes they got 15,000 between them
and the winners use the following
project so there was dssm Microsoft
cognitive services which I think there's
also going to be a talk about here it
used to be called Project Oxford XIII
which is a verifier language and CNT k
so these were the popular projects with
these students and they came from all
over the world and did fantastic work on
the open source projects finally this is
my summary if you want to have open
source you can do it in different ways
and you can have external input that
forces you to go open source you can
have single Reapers or more repos you
can have a push to a foundation and so
on versions for all platforms I've
mentioned you can ship with major
platforms and inside major platforms
timing is not important you can go open
source at different times but the main
thing is you need communities of
developers and that is where you all
come in so I hope then in the projects
in the research showcase that are open
source you'll perhaps talk more deeply
to the sea the developers who are out
there and ask them about and see whether
you can contribute and work with us
through this mechanism and we'd be
delighted to have you thanks
very nice to to thank you we have a few
minutes for questions does anybody have
anything they want to start off with I
know it's early oh good hello good
morning thanks for your presentation I
was curious about the bubble where
Moodle appears together with Microsoft
could you please talk about initiatives
from Microsoft regarding educational
tools and maybe open source tools
regarding that subject Microsoft has
many educational tools now obviously
there are the ones which assists
everybody in education such as one note
and the office platform and so on then
there are the more serious ones which
are for programming so are you which
ones are you intending in the inner
presentation their burrows the education
yeah with mud mud oh yeah okay gotcha so
the educational tools are the ones which
are there for helping with it with
coding so let's take for example touch
develop that would be one of the typical
ones that's listed under there and the
idea would be that this is something new
something fresh and we interested
extremely interested in finding out how
other people particularly in education
and in academia would want to use that
and through the open source model they
might be able to extend it with us so
that that is part of it I think the best
thing is if you come to the research
showcase
and I can explore more of those with you
and show them to you good good question
is there any particular license which is
the most used one for Microsoft open
projects yes in fact I have the picture
here so this is the spectrum of licenses
which is a worldwide diagram of open
source taken from github actually and
the big blue thing up at the top there
is the MIT license and that is the one
that's recommended now within Microsoft
to use the next one down below is the
the GPL we don't recommend that one in
Microsoft as much and the reason is here
the permissive ones are the ones we
recommend more which means that you can
attribute in other words you recognize
when you send out the code you say I got
this code from this place and when you
use it you must also say you got it from
this place but the restrictive ones are
like the GPL ones and and we find those
very difficult to work with so Microsoft
Works much more with the MIT good one
more
thank you it's oh no my students had
been internet microsoft research and one
common complaint is that they were in
allowed to use open source software in
their projects so that has policy change
and in general how is the use of open
source in Microsoft Project with that
Microsoft Research and they weren't
allowed to use it yeah yeah they weren't
allowed to use open source a bit because
they were afraid of some sort of a
contamination yeah the code that they
were developing so what is important to
know is that there is a process by which
we even if you go back here once you
incorporate open source within your own
project you have to make sure that that
is identified forever right and the soul
I think that that process has is handled
by our release team by our open source
team and it is a large team of people
who ensure that Microsoft or any company
would do this Microsoft's not unique
that would ensure that when anything
then goes outside the company we can't
get sued by not having the correct
licenses around all the pieces of
software so it's very likely than for
numerous reasons depending on the size
of what your students are doing that it
might have been better to write it
themselves all because of time
constraints because I have to say that
going through this process is at least a
six week a process but it's worthwhile
because once you've done it you've got
it
but it might well have been that the
owner of whatever was going on felt that
it you know the wadded up and said let's
not use the open source here but it
would not have been a decision that
would have been anti open source it
would have been made for other reasons I
suspect yeah or maybe the that was
awhile back and now we're in a newer
mode that's great Thank You Judith I'm
going to go ahead and wrap it up there
let's please give her another warm
welcome birth thank you